[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans cette
édition du 7 8 journal sur tv 60,18 les
titres de ce mardi 23 janvier malgré les
rumeurs de la métropole du grand paris
il souhaite toujours fusionner yvelines
et hauts-de-seine ont présenté ce matin
leur budget commun à jouy en josas est
les deux collectivités gèrent ensemble
des politiques publiques et veulent
renforcer leur collaboration le point à
suivre
c'est un club d'entreprises socialement
engagées localement impliqué facile il
agit en faveur de l'employabilité et de
l'accès à l'emploi plusieurs moyens pour
y parvenir notamment des job academy qui
fonctionne au travers d'actions de
parrainage mohamed mansouri est notre
invité il est le directeur de phase iib
bling et puis votre rendez vous
hebdomadaire le portrait de la rédaction
comme chaque mardi 27 8 journal elle est
devenue miss fitness france 2018 et elle
est yvelinoise qui a dit baradji a
remporté le concours en novembre dernier
à nous avons rencontré la vie sinoise
lors d'un entraînement et nous parlerons
également de la deuxième partie de la
saison à la merise attrape avec notre
deuxième invité francis costes a requis
le directeur de la salle c'était il ya
vingt ans le 23 janvier 1998 11
personnes dont 9 collégiens de saint
françois d'assise à montigny le
bretonneux amour est dans une avalanche
aux orres dans les hautes-alpes est la
catastrophe avait largement ému en
france vous le voyez sur ces images des
milliers de personnes étaient venues
assister aux obsèques aux gymnases à
pierre de coubertin transformée en
chapelle ardente
en ce jour de commémoration une messe de
recueillement a eu lieu au collège saint
françois d'assise une cérémonie intime
en présence des familles étaient
également prévues par la mairie de
montigny le bretonneux
je vous le disais en titre les yvelines
et l'ofc elle toujours sur la voie de la
fusion réunis au sein d'un établissement
public interdépartemental les deux
collectivités ont voté leur budget ce
matin à jouy en josas à des dépenses de
fonctionnement pour financer les
politiques publiques gérées en commun et
une volonté renforcer la collaboration
un sujet de nick
attendre plus de 15 millions d'euros
c'est le budget 2010 8 adopté lors du
conseil d'administration de
l'établissement public
interdépartemental yvelines hauts de
seine avec une large majorité des
dépenses de fonctionnement des services
d'adoption d'entretien des routes et
d'archéologie des domaines mise en
commun entre les deux collectivités
c'est un budget qui est dans la
continuité du processus de fusion que
nous avons engagées
c'est un processus progressif mais aussi
réversible notre objectif c'est
effectivement de faire fusionner nos
deux départements de manière à n'en
former qu'un seul l'adoption de ce
budget montre la détermination des élus
à aller au bout de la fusion un point de
vue partagé par nicolas dainville nommé
président de la commission développement
économique et tourisme à la place de son
prédécesseur jean michel fourgous
montrer l'importance des coopérations
qui peut y avoir entre nos départements
yvelines et hauts-de-seine sur ces
enjeux là de développement économique
c'est très important et de tourisme on a
des synergies à trouver et donc ça est
l'enjeu de la commission trouver des
synergies et des coopérations à
l'échelle de nos deux territoires
la fusion des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine reste la priorité de
pierre bédier de patrick devedjian
ils restent aussi mobilisées avec les
autres présidents de départements d'île
de france pour s'opposer au projet de
métropole du grand paris
la présentation de budget donc pour les
yvelines et les hauts-de-seine la ville
de montigny le bretonneux elle
présentait ses voeux à la population
c'était hier à la ferme du manet
première cérémonie du genre pour le
maire dvd jean luc ourgaud élu en
octobre un discours sous les yeux de ses
deux prédécesseurs nicolas à bout et
michel laugier le président du sénat
gérard larcher la présidente de la
région valérie pécresse et le patron du
département des yvelines pierre bédier
étaient également présents propos
recueillis par nicolas kirillovitch
c'est vraiment effectivement un moment
particulier parce que vous imaginez bien
que même si je suis élu depuis 25 ans
entre le 30 juin et être mère c'est deux
choses complètement différentes
d'une part puis de l'autre avoir comme
deux prédécesseurs nicolas à bout et
michel laugier ça me mettais je dirais
la barre très haute
de telle sorte à ce que j'essaye de
faire au mieux pour cette cérémonie qui
était certes ma première cérémonie de
voeux
je tenais aussi bien sûr à rendre
hommage à michel laugier un grand projet
de cette année à montigny le bretonneux
la déconstruction de l'ancien collège
bergson le site accueillera à terme un
nouveau pôle culturel et 136 logements
est les premiers coups de pioche
devraient commencer dans les prochains
jours eux étaient vendredi les voeux les
voeux de saint-cyr-l'ecole au théâtre
gérard philipe le maire bernard de bain
est revenu sur l'année 2010 est
notamment sur l'ouverture de l'école
jacqueline de romilly et de ses seize
classes est des projets qui vont se
poursuivre cette année dans la ville d
ouverture mais aussi le début de
nombreux chantiers le point sur tous ces
dossiers au micro de patrick jacques de
dixmude les débuts des travaux
longtemps attendu
du haut le bizet wallon l'école et la
maison de quartier
l'ouverture d'une structure pour
réserver aux personnes âgées
et puis en ce qui concerne la zac renard
nous avons la fin de la construction
d'une crèche de 60 berceaux le gymnase
dont
travaux vont bientôt commencer ainsi que
la maison des associations il a été créé
en 1999 par des entreprises de saint
quentin en yvelines fasse mine c'est un
club d'entreprises contre l'exclusion
bosson bonsoir moi événement sourit ce
soit merci d'être avec nous vous êtes le
directeur de fass civile vous vous
définissez comme un club d'entreprises
socialement engagé et localement
impliqués qu'est ce que ça veut dire
concrètement quelles sont les missions
de facile et là bas ça veut dire en fait
concrètement à gérer au quotidien
effectivement sur nos deux champs
d'action qui sont l'emploi et puis
l'école donc sur l'emploi concrètement
effectivement l'objectif 7 favoriser
l'employabilité et l'accès le retour à
l'emploi des personnes effectivement qui
sont en recherche d'emploi et puis sur
l'axé cole s'est effectivement
intervenir pour rapprocher monde
économique et univers éducatif et puis
favorise effectivement l'inclusion
scolaire
on va revenir sur ses différentes
missions 96 1110 demandeurs d'emploi
dans les yvelines ça c'est en novembre
les chiffres de décembre seront connus
demain justement face yvelines vous en
avez parlé est engagé en faveur de
l'employabilité et l'accès à l'emploi
vous êtes d'ailleurs fait partie du
réseau national de la fondation agir
contre l'exclusion
pourquoi finalement ce combat contre
l'exclusion qui est pourquoi est il
important
abbas est un combat essentiel puisqu'il
effectivement on peut pas laisser sur le
bord de la route des personnes qui sont
en nécessité donc c'est effectivement
l'objet la fondation qui a été créée en
93 donc il ya plus de vingt ans
maintenant
aujourd'hui c'est une fondation qui est
présidée par monsieur mestrallet donc
pdg du groupe
angie et puis localement retrouve
effectivement des entreprises à la tête
de la fondation ce qui est le cas pour
nous facilitent puisque c'est thales qui
est président de la fondation et puis on
trouve d'autres groupes comme ag2r la
mondiale et puis la caisse d'epargne ile
de france donc c'est vraiment agir au
quotidien aux côtés du monde économique
au bénéfice des publics sur les
territoires aujourd'hui d'en face une
ligne à combien d'entreprises engagées
alors aujourd'hui on est sur 80
entreprises s'impliquent au quotidien
sachant que ces entreprises ça peut être
effectivement des tpe des pme ou des
grands groupes nous ce qui importe c'est
effectivement c'est l'implication
effective une entreprise au travers de
nos actions alors vous avez parlé
justement
émission d actions un travail qui est
mené notamment aider l'école l'une des
missions vous en avez parlé moi
événement souris c'est de rapprocher le
monde économique et le monde et éducatif
comment ça peut se mettre en place sa
commune pour pour nous c'est essentiel
parce que s'ils vont effectivement
préparer l'avenir des des jeunes pour
demain c'est intervenir dès maintenant
dans les établissements scolaires donc
c'est effectivement dans les actions
qu'on met en place on a des actions de
découverte métier mon a également des
projets pédagogiques qui s'inscrit
pendant toute une toute une année par
exemple on a organisé l'année dernière
en projet de graines l'entreprise où on
a une classe de 4e du collège de trappes
qui a été accompagné par des ingénieurs
de thales pour créer une clé usb qui a
été racheté par thales donc 500 clefs
usb ont été fabriqués par les jeunes de
trappes et ensuite ont été distribués
auprès des clients de talent est donc
500 clés qui ont été distribués à
l'international c'est à dire au brésil
au qatar
donc vraiment qui a traversé tout le
monde entier après on organise aussi des
opérations type speed dating métier où
là on va faire venir à peu près 100 une
centaine d'élèves rencontrés
effectivement des entreprises des chefs
d'entreprise pour justement les initiés
dans un parcours d'orientation scolaire
et professionnelle alors autres missions
et cette troisième grand axe 2 faces
yvelines placer l'entreprise au coeur de
l'égalité ça servait exactement puisque
si on veut que l'entreprise soit
impliqué sur ces sujets là qui soit
l'égalité où la diversité effectivement
il faut l'amener là sensibiliser la
compagne et la forme et au mieux sur ces
thématiques là est donc effectivement là
ça prend la forme d'ateliers
interentreprises où on va évoquer
plusieurs sujets en lien avec les
questions de diversité
on va mettre en place aussi des guides
de bonnes pratiques pour justement
encourager les entreprises à investir ce
champ là et puis effectivement on va
aussi fort mais l'entreprise sur par
exemple la belle diversité sur ce
travail avec les entreprises et à des
actions qui sont mis en place bien sûr
on va parler des job academy dans un
instant il ya aussi d immersion dans le
milieu professionnel qui sont proposés
par facilement oui oui tout à fait en
fait le
le but de l'immersion c'est de permettre
aux chercheurs d'emploi d'avoir une
vision très concrète du métier et de
l'environnement professionnel et donc là
effectivement on est sûr d immersion qui
ont cet objectif là et donc ça permet
effectivement aux chercheurs d'emploi
d'avancer dans leur projet et de mieux
se situer par rapport à leurs métiers
ciblés il nous reste un peu plus d'une
minute trente pour parler de cette
mission face cette action le job academy
qui a mis en place en fait c'est des
promotions de demandeurs d'emplois qui
vont être accompagnés par des parrains
au sein d'une entreprise
voilà exactement donc c'est en fait une
entreprise qui va mettre à disposition
un groupe de collaborateurs noyage qu'on
appelle les parrains marraines qui vont
accompagner individuellement et
collectivement des personnes en
recherche d'emploi et ce qui est
intéressant dans cette dans cette action
là c'est vraiment ce lien direct et
dynamique entre la personne et puis une
représentant de l'entreprise et
d'apporter ce regard entreprise qui est
l'employeur potentiel donc y'a pas mieux
comme regard que qu'une entreprise pour
effectivement évalué l'employabilité
d'une personne en recherche d'emploi et
notamment un troisième job academy qui a
été mis en place avec le château de
versailles ça on en a parlé il ya
quelques jours dans le journal
l'idée s'est proposé par cour enfin a
suivi on va dire groupé avec plusieurs
demandeurs d'emploi mais aussi un suivi
individualisé y aller 2 1 de ce job
voilà ses ventes combinées à la fois des
ateliers collectifs sur des sujets tels
que par exemple et la recherche d'emploi
sur les réseaux sociaux tels que des cd
vidéo avec de l'accompagnement
individualisé qui sera mis en oeuvre par
les collaborateurs de l'entreprise
partenaire donc avec deux rendez vous
par mois dans les locaux de l'entreprise
plus un atelier collectif sur quatre
mois à peu près d'accompagnement en
moyenne donc un vrai programme très
complet très dynamique très innovant
pour permettre aux personnes d'être dans
cette phase active de retour à l'emploi
depuis la création du club en tout cas
depuis cinq ans maintenant
ouais c'est une action qui fait partie
prenante de notre projet sur le
territoire et donc depuis cinq ans ce
sont 16 jobs académique ont été mises en
place 200 personnes accompagnées sur les
job academy et le ressort à l'emploi
près
revenez sur 150 retour à l'emploi donc
on est quand même sur un taux d'à peu
près 75 % de retour à l'emploi l'issue
d'une job academy on a dépassé le temps
mais très rapidement je sais que vous
vouliez lancé un appel pour les
prochains job academy
oui voilà tout à fait donc on a
effectivement cette dynamique là on a
qu'on a plusieurs job academy qui vont
se mettre en place courant du du
trimestre vos coordonnées apparaissent
d'ailleurs à l'écran voilà donc
effectivement s'il ya des personnes qui
sont intéressées justement pour être
accompagnés sur des job academy peuvent
nous contacter auprès d'eux auprès de la
structure
merci moi même en sort il avoir établi
un nouveau directeur de facilité je
rappelle que vous pouvez retrouver
toutes ces informations sur le site
internet et aux numéros de téléphone qui
s'affiche
chaque année plus de 3000 personnes
perdent la vie sur les routes en france
en cause la vitesse la prise d'acte
d'alcool et de stupéfiants avant de
prendre le volant les jeunes sont des
cibles particulièrement concernée c'est
justement pour des étudiants qui était
destinée cette action de sensibilisation
aujourd'hui à hec ans jouait à jouy en
josas un bus itinérant pour échanger
autour de la sécurité routière sujet de
patrick jacques de dixmude et de camille
lambert
maxime amis 0,72 secondes pour réagir au
coup de sifflet effrénée sur route sèche
sa distance de freinage et de 37 mètres
sur route mouillée 58 m même si j'étais
préparé à freiner au moment où il y
aurait eu l'oeil allait avoir le bruit
et ben même l'âge avec a maintenant la
réaction n'était pas loin d'une seconde
donc c'est vrai que c'est ce que
disaient les gens qui nous accompagnait
la base c'est que c'était que même en
conditions réelles ce serait pire en
termes de temps de réaction quoi
simulateur de conduite casque de réalité
virtuelle
ce bus toutes équipées et là pour
sensibiliser les étudiants de l'école de
commerce hec à la sécurité routière
une démarche menée par une entreprise de
location de véhicules d'entreprises dans
toute la france
le bus dans lequel nous trouver qui est
à comporte donc cette cet atelier va
aller dans cette ville de france donc le
tour de france a déjà démarré par les
villes de rennes se poursuit à paris
puis ensuite ce bus ira sur lyon annecy
par exemple sur l'alcool au volant ils
n'ont pas du tout là
l'impression de boire et de ne plus être
maîtres de leur véhicule le test pour
leur fait faire leur montre que à deux
verres d'alcool
les réactions et les temps de réponse on
sort sont amoindris de l'alcool au
volant serait responsable de 30% des
accidents de la route en france
pour rappel la limite autorisée par la
loi et de 0 5 gramme d'alcool par litre
de sang
chaque année ce sont plus de 3000
personnes qui perdent la vie sur les
routes du territoire
une sensibilisation qui s'est déroulé
hier et non pas aujourd'hui hec alors
cette action d'entre aide s'est déroulée
à travers toute la france une marche
solidaire de 300 kilomètres au départ
d'angers elle est arrivée dimanche au
champ de mars à paris à l'initiative
lancée par l'association la solidarité
courent les rues a fait étape samedi à
versailles retour avec mélanie poquet et
nicolas kirillovitch
[Musique]
jeff marche depuis le 7 janvier
membre de la solidarité pour les rues il
veut sensibiliser à la pauvreté et
dénoncer la misère pour toutes les
exactions que les migrants et les
réfugiés subissent après tout ce qu'ils
ont vécu on continue de les traiter
comme des moins que rien et c'est
absolument pas normal
et pour pour dire que plus personne
quel que soit nationalité carte
d'identité ou pas ne doit dormir à la
rue et ne doit mourir à la rue on a en
permanence à peu près six marcheurs sur
chaque étape avec des roulements et des
gens qui qui nous rejoignent au fur et à
mesure sur les sur les étapes
ils sont partis dans j'ai un peu plus de
300 km de marche une douzaine d'étapes
et le lancement d'une pétition
et oui voilà ans si on fait déjà
participé par une petite signature ça
serait cool c'est déjà un bon début
j'ai après ménager du temps pour faire
bonne figure et aller sur place c'est
déjà un bon début
normalement oui aucun problème je suive
rapidement obligé j'aurais pas le
courage à faire autant de kilomètres
leur périple a pris fin le 21 janvier
plus de 200 personnes se sont retrouvées
sur le champ de mars à paris
la pétition a recueilli près de 800
signatures
c'est une salle emblématique du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
la merise attrape s'apprête à vivre sa
deuxième partie de saison bonsoir
francis costard bonsoir vous êtes le
directeur de la merise déjà un mot sur
la première partie de saison elle était
riche éclectique du théâtre avec
marivaux de la danse avec prismatique du
rap avec m hd ou encore du jazz avec
andré manoukian qu'elle
l'on vous tirer de cette première partie
de saison à la nourrice et bien
[Musique]
une forte mobilité
enfin mobilisation des gens au niveau du
territoire mais beaucoup de gens de tram
mais une bonne très bonne foi cadre
fréquentation pour l'instant voilà et ce
qui est bien c'est très varié et que
c'est lé public complètement différent
qui viennent à se mélanger et qui
viennent à découvrir notre saison et qui
vont je pense continuer à venir sur les
prochaines dates sur le nouveau
trimestre pour preuve que la dives et
qui à la diversité à la merise la
programmation reprend en 2018 dès ce
dimanche à 20h30 avec un concert de
musique classique celle orchestre hélios
qui viendra la merise et c'est dans le
cadre de la nuit des conservatoires
cette programmation alors non à
exactement à la base reprécisant les
autorités c'est un concert qui avait
décidé de
qu'on le fasse à la nourrice
m'intéressait c'était la proximité
quelques lui pouvait avoir avec
justement la musique classique et on
trouvait qu'à la mairie il y avait trop
de distance entre notre public est
justement ce hélios voilà et on voulait
vraiment rapproché et donc on s'est dit
pourquoi pas profiter justement de la
nuit du conservatoire pour faire
déplacer est né ce qu'on appelle du hors
les murs et d'amener justement notre
public a justement à fréquenter
également l'école de musique et de danse
de trappes au travers donc de musique
classique on se déplace en ce qu'on
appelle du hors les murs ça nous est
arrivé également pour andré manoukian on
est on avait la prestation eu lieu à
l'église saint-georges de trappes donc
on fait du hors les murs on ne reste pas
uniquement voilà dans l'eau dans la
salle de la sérieuse il a alors le mois
de février débutera lui avec de la danse
roméo et juliette donc ces tendances
justement par elephant in black box et
compagnie et là le ballet national
d'espagne
ça sera le vendredi 2 février à 20h30
tout à fait donc ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que c'est un mélange
entre à la fois la musique classique est
également une histoire que tout le monde
connaît au logis est mais une rencontre
avec le flamenco d'accord donc vous avez
les deux familles qui viennent à
s'affronter gens connaissent l'histoire
mais laquelle elle est monté lui que
vous avez tout à fait et donc les deux
familles donc famille en classique et
familles de flamenco qui vient donc une
rencontre
et puis on a quand même
je fait du rig dansant l'opéra de paris
qui vient danser chez nous voilà et si
c'est quelque chose de magnifique soulas
à la fois il ya de la danse donc
classique flamenco de la vidéo il ya une
partie très théâtralisé et voilà donc
c'est très intéressant à voir et à venir
voir sur cette notion
c'était avant le vendredi 2 février à
20h30 à la merise alors toujours en
février le 10 février
plus précisément à 20h30 la merise
accueille deux des plus grandes figures
de la musique kabyle lounis aït
menguellet et id hier alors c'est un
concert qui est déjà complet
malheureusement oui
en tout cas c'est une chance doit
d'avoir ces deux grandes figures à la
merise bassée c'était une volonté
ça nous est déjà arrivé de recevoir
plusieurs fois et dire notamment en
invité l'année précédente avec les
motiver et on en avait discuté à la fin
de ce concert si je reviendrais bien ici
et pourquoi pas se serait dit j'aime
bien trappe et j'ai envie de revenir
j'ai mes propres acteurs une belle
soirée kabyle en invitant aussi l'aunis
est un galette donc deux stars de la
kabylie
tiens présence solide en france et donc
on les a invités et c'est vrai désolé il
ya certaines personnes qui ne pourront
pas venir puisque c'est déjà complet
elle a donc on peut pas pousser des
millions je suis désolé voilà déjà
complet sur cet axe à une autre
programmation qui est déjà complète lots
6 une performance visuelle s'appelle
pixels oui ça sera avant le 10 mars à
20h30 willow 10 mars et c'est également
au complet je suis dès ce fait oui
pixels
donc c'est une des rares fois que ça
passe sur le territoire
voilà c'est de la danse hip hop voilà
donc c'est la compagne et de mourad
merzouki qui présente sa donc à font
danser avec des pixels noyer donc tout
mélange de voix là de deux trois
dimensions et les gens se retrouvent à
bouger à la fois c'est du cirque à la
freddy du mouvement c'est vraiment très
beau c'est voilà c'est ça ne m'étonne
pas qu'on est vite remplie voilà et on
reçoit beaucoup de scolaires dessus très
bien il faut le savoir aussi donc c'est
ça qui est intéressant c'est que on
accueille aussi et dans le monde
scolaire et ce soit là où roméo juliette
également alors il n'y a pas que des
programmation complète rassurez-vous à
la merise on va faire un saut dans le
temps on n'a pas le temps de parler
malheureusement de toutes les
programmations sur cette deuxième partie
de saison on a vu du théâtre de la
musique de la danse pas encore l'humour
est justement le samedi 9 juin à 20h30 à
l'humoriste vérino sera à la merise on
l'avait connu notamment la télé dans
l'émission on n'demande qu'à en rire sur
france 2 et là donc il propose son
spectacle qui cartonne en france qui
fonctionne plutôt bien et il a fait une
belle saison au point virgule
dont on grands projets reculé de 2 et là
il vient un peu partout en france c'est
une belle tournée qui s'annonce
il a toujours été dit donc internet qui
passe sur tous les réseaux sociaux donc
voilà ça marche très très bien pour lui
on aime bien voilà que vous lui disiez
bas la prévention de la merise c'est à
la fois de la danse et d'humour du
théâtre sur l'a10 jeune public également
on a de la musique différents styles on
parlait de cabinda nord mais on va vous
n'avez pas parlé mais on va aussi
accueillir vitalic aux musiques
électroniques sur une grande scène donc
de 19h 30 à 2 heures du matin dédié aux
musiques électroniques
donc voilà des jets qui viendront donc
c'est vrai que la mairie c'est ça c'est
cette richesse au niveau de la probation
et cette diversité c'est dans vos dires
c'est notre force
vous avez 15 secondes pour terminer sur
la toute dernière programmation de cette
année 2017 2018 cette saison 2017-2018 à
la mairie speakeasy alors saisi
programmation cirque autour des films
les films de gangsters
alors il ya à la fois cette partie film
de gangsters de côté circassiens et tous
à orchestrer sur une musique de chinese
man donc ça va si tu connaissais
voilà donc
c'est un mélange à la fois de de toute
la partie sensible vous avez autour du
cirque
donc ça soit dumas que ce soit de
l'acrobatie la jonglerie ses
contemporains et tourné comme un film en
noir et blanc au temps de la prohibition
il ya donc tout un fils et une histoire
qui va se dérouler voilà on va se
retrouver dans un café du temps de la
prohibition avec cette musique très
entraînante et avec six artistes voilà
qui vont entraîner sur voilà donc ça se
fera au mois de juillet le 3 juillet
exactement à 20h30 merci francis d'avoir
été à directeur de la merise et vous
pouvez retrouver toute la programmation
très complète sur le site de la mairie
ce qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci
d'avoir été avec nous avant de se
quitter le portrait de la rédaction
c'est une habitude le mardi dans cette
suite journal ce soir focus sur une
première dans les yvelines qui a dit
baradji a été élue miss fitness france
2010 8,7 vie sinoise de 29 ans pratique
la musculation aux deux à trois fois par
semaine pour remporter le concours
elle a été évaluée notamment sur le
développé couché les pompes le squat ou
encore sur l'endurance une rencontre
signé michael ni doro mails et mélanie
poker
[Musique]
une vraie force de la nature à 29 ans
caddie baradji réalise en moyenne de 25
heures de sport par semaine et peut
soulever jusqu'à 80 kg des performances
qui lui ont permis de devenir miss
fitness france à créteil en novembre
dernier j'avais vraiment envie de me
dépasser et de d'arriver au bout et de
me dire j'ai fait tout ce que je pouvais
que je gagne ou pas en fait de d'être
allé au bout de moi même dans une
compétition ce n'est pas mon domaine en
fait pour réaliser cet exploit cet
ancien athlète et tenniswoman d'un mètre
soixante huit pour 60 kg a dû remporter
plusieurs épreuves sur une journée un
concours loin d'être une promenade de
santé et avec des séances de force un
peu qu'avec squat développé couché
il y avait des pompes à des tractions
des abdos des lombaires et un gros
circuit un peu cheap comme ce que je
viens de faire là et c'était vraiment
complet pour remporter ces épreuves
spartiates kddi a travaillé pendant un
mois de façon intense avec son
entraîneur dans cette salle de maurepas
je savais qu'elle allait gagner
sans aucun doute c'est fou tout le temps
soyez tout le temps zumba la danse
tennis crossfit vitesse tout ce qu'ils
ont volé en permanence musculation le
jour et encore du sport le soir en
parallèle de ces grosses séances de
fitness caddie donne des cours de
pilates de renforcement musculaire et
surtout de zumba cinq fois par semaine
entre voisins le bretonneux et montigny
le bretonneux
allez les filles on y va du parti pour
moi personnellement je préfère faire les
pompes et les tractions met à enseigner
à la zumba c'est vraiment très sympa ça
allie la dépense physique et le et le
plaisir en fait c'est à dire que c'est
vraiment fun on se rend pas compte qu'on
est dans l'effort
[Musique]
chaque soir une vingtaine d'élèves
viennent participer à ces sessions ce
sont eux qui l'ont poussé à s'inscrire
au concours miss fitness france la
victoire de la professeur a donc été
accueillie avec de grands sourires à
bord
l'histoire de caddie avec le monde du
sport n'est pas prêt de se terminer la
sportive envisage de défendre son titre
de miss fitness france l'année prochaine
et de participer à d'autres concours
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal très
bonne soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]